there are definitely some upsides to
having the animatronics in the movie be
legit for starters they were created by
Jim Henson's Creature Shop and if
there's one name that gives credibility
in the world of animatronics and puppets
it's Henson apparently a sizable chunk
of the 20 million movie budget went to
Henson's crew and I'm sure everyone is
happy about that cuz the creatures all
look incredible another cool aspect is
how involved and complex they are for
example it apparently takes six people
to operate the character foxy each
person is moving a separate part of her
body and they have to work in sync to
make things look realistic hella cool of
course having no CG and all animatronic
creatures had some challenges too for
starters it took 15 months for the
Hensen Creature Shop to build them all
so that likely caused some delays on a
movie that was already seriously delayed
over the years